you can really no no double find games
in there oh I'm sorry let's redo that
it's live it's F yeah we just roll back
time we roll back time hello welcome to
Lobby gam spots weekly hangout every
Tuesday 2 p.m. Pacific right here on
gamespot.com uh we've had a lot of
changes here at Gamespot we've decided
to change up the show decided to make it
a little bit longer and I'd like to
introduce high quality guests three of
our no our new staffers from the world
of video games uh Tim Schaefer decided
to leave game development and join us
here why why was it for the attention to
finally have someone see me I wanted to
come where all the eyeballs are what's
the first review you're doing for
videogames.com um I was going to check
out that um Halloween RPG game a little
bit subjectively give you my um what
have you heard about it I've heard this
amazing like transformative experience
to play it just better than any scale
that could be used to rank any game well
Gabe Miller was actually the lead on
that project I think it's called what's
called spook Adventure C Quest Too Close
yeah spook Adventures you should have
got that that.com is probably not to but
Christmas is still available okay oh
yeah and BR Shoemaker from our um he
also quit yeah he quit I guess I work at
Double find now that subscription model
wasn't working out you decided to come
over to the the world of back to gam
spot you guys have like nice wood
paneling on the floor and stuff fancy
over here you like it here yeah I have
an Oma 600 like a corner of someone's
office nice Legend statue back there
people see I don't think people on the
floor where nobody can see it yeah we'll
move that up it's right beside big rigs
so that's where we put all our best
games anyway uh costume came out today
oh yeah happy costum yeahoo can I get
one yeah yeah yeah yeah thanks for
helping is it no you don't you know okay
got to do at least a couple of weeks in
double F before you get your hand clap
uh it's out four years after the first
one which makes everyone feel super old
and wow at least four years old 2010 mhm
and you guys have released a million
games since then cost Quest was our
first smaller game like after Brutal
Legend we that's when we started like
let's take this team and make four games
at once instead of like 10 years for our
first two games we made like four games
in one year two years and Costume Quest
was like the first one that we released
that was the Amnesia fortnite stuff
right wasia fortnite is like what we
call our game Jam where we take two
weeks and we just uh make four games in
a week and two weeks and then um um
Costume Quest came out of that and then
um Gabe was on that and he was the
producer and then he was uh kind of
director kind of on the DLC grubbins
yeah wrote all the dialogue for the DLC
and so he was the best person to uh run
the sequel It's like a completely
different country in those four years or
company rather we are a different
country you are a country it used to be
a our high level domain and we are our
own DF I like the way that sounds it's
probably if you there probably is a
country that has DF like the Dominican
fun public or something we could use I
want to live
there so yeah it's h what made you come
back to one of them obvious you've made
all these different types of games
you're one of the most like interesting
development studios in terms of like
just your reach in different types of
yeah well make sure you come on again
you know when we first pitched I if you
remember this but when we first pitched
uh cost Quest a lot of Publishers were
like we really like it Halloween based
RPG but could you take out the Halloween
why cuz like people will only buy it uh
at Halloween they won't buy it anymore
which the funny thing about that is they
might there is this bump in sales when
you launch it in Halloween just like all
games but then the next year comes
around and people play it again like we
see like people buy it again the next
year in this funny kind of ritual like
the same way that you might when you're
a kid watch the Charlie Brown special
every year and you have that urge to
like I just want to immerse myself in
the pumpkin patch Charlie Brown the
leaves blowing The Ghost and um so you
guys are like the Mariah Carey of game
development wait how'd you get there
from Charlie Brown lius Mar care oh I
see yeah the Christmas album this is
like our Mariah Carey Christmas album
did you think that that might happen
like were you completely believe this
the idea to like a seasonal game no of
course we had this all planned out very
well thought out thing but it came
around and the other thing that comes
around is people's uh remember the game
because it's Halloween they're like oh
yeah remember that it's like this
built-in marketing thing and people are
like remember that game they should make
a sequel to that and I'm going to Tweet
Tim and tell them to make a sequel and
then basically people don't know that
but if you tweet enough times we were
legally obligated to make a is that what
happen with grim Fango as well
apparently great yeah okay
so cor they just asked for it we just
want to give people what they want all
right let's let's give them what they
want let's actually have a look at the
video game spook Adventure spook
Adventure 3 this is Gabe Miller did we
introduce Gabe Miller yeah he's playing
the game M you're what we call driving
this what we call Gleaming the Cube this
is the start menu this is also where the
DLC left off with the Cliffhanger which
portal you go
through this is start menu I feel like
it's breaking some like Xbox Live arcade
rule set you we haven't passed TCR yet
so maybe that's careful
yeah great what the heck is this this of
course is not live spook Adventure
assume this is not live that was a great
I knew I should have
drove yeah don't worry we we'll try and
get start a new game yeah start a new
game it might have been those did you go
from the save game yeah we brought some
saves over and direct de's fault
whenever that happens we always blame
direct de can you remember any like
other seasonal games there was a game on
the amig I used to play all the time
called psycho Santa that was free with I
never played wasn't there a Christmas
version of
nights really was there Christmas nights
Christmas was was called Christmas
nights any know Christmas games when you
type Christmas into the Giant Bomb Wiki
what stuff comes up Christmas nights and
that's it is that a plug for the Giant
Bomb Wiki which is sure that the keeper
of all knowled subscribe world's most
amazing video game database so start a
new
game there that saves probably I can
kill that one yeah just go to the bottom
oh okay I
see we got
fixed it here you go don't crash again
if everyone on the stream could cross
their fingers I'm you see how I
masterfully hacked that that's why we
keep they keep you around I've been
wondering if everyone on stream could
cross their fingers and pray to their
respective gods that doesn't crash again
that' be Super Rad uh yeah so what made
you was it just people tweeting what was
it about this that made you want to make
a second one yeah I I really liked it I
liked the first game it was one of the
first games it was the first game that
we made that it wasn't from an idea that
I had you know it was like idea that
Tasha had that she um had when she was a
kid was like I want to make an RPG like
Halloween she loved Halloween and um and
so I I did help a little bit with some
dialogue and I wrote some some scenes
but U mostly it was a game that people
at my company made and I got to play
like a first timer like oh man often I
you know it's all spoiled for me because
I yeah cuz you're involved too close to
it yeah yeah I liked it it's got a great
just like that Charlie Brown special has
this great I feel like this mood and has
this um sense of humor they're like like
and yet it's got a kind of spooky
Scooby-Do thing going on I guess
whenever whenever Halloween comes around
everyone goes in and starts playing like
scary games again like Amnesia and I
guess PT this year there's probably a
bunch of people are going to play or
like the old alien vers Predator one you
can play with your kids too you could
play like families play together and you
can play you play the switch kids yeah I
always assumed when it came out of this
you being like a a father that this was
like your so it's interesting that
actually this has nothing to do with
like creatively it was not you weren't
invol no I did play it with my daughter
she was really young though so she could
just press the x button when it was time
to launch special powers but this time
I'm hoping to she she's going to have to
be reading
it you played you play you completed the
first one as well bro right
yep he didn't say he liked it that's
enjoyed it quite a bit sted right there
I did play it and I had opinions about
it I finished it did you enjoy it yes
totally that's better did you do the
review for joh bom I did gave it a two
out of five we bring that up yep
they're above numbers now beyond that y
so is this a direct sequel to gromin on
I it's like starts straight away it does
kind a continuous story yeah grubbin
ends with those portals and so it starts
right here and um should we talk about
what's happening you're actually wearing
the costumes that you had at the end
they selected one of the portals to jump
through in their home but it's Halloween
for some reason so they're talking about
that and you actually got to pick
whether you're Ren or Reynold again
already or is that yeah I chose Ren yeah
so you still get to pick whether you're
Ren or Reynold oh I see an evil dentist
in the background people have asked if
we have things against dentists is that
every just incidental that he's a
dentist it's an omage to um he's a guy
with problems and he happens to be a
dentist he's a guy with problems he just
happens to be a dentist he's got great
teeth I used to have a dentist that had
really terrible teeth and then years
later I thought did she just put on like
like real [__] just to make me freak
out and be like God I better that's a
really funny dentist but did she do it
over and over again every time you came
well I don't know I don't know they
might have been real she might have
actually just had really bad dental
hygiene and then made it her like life's
work to make sure that I know they had
dentist in England in England I don't
know what they have in England Brad in
the UK also not in the UK Brad in that
part makes up fake countries but at
least he doesn't redraw political
borders in that part of the world let's
say you're the worst I could I can make
that mistake cuz I'm new here but you
should have known that you lived in
London for a few years I did yeah that
does make me didn't say wi somewhere in
the Commonwealth what do you call them
the places that have Queens on their
money just say you're we don't have a
queen on our money don't no we we had
like animals and stuff and then EU got
involved you never been to Ireland I've
never been to Ireland I've been you've
been to Ireland yeah did you like it I
did if you could review arand out of 10
points what would you give it we don't
do review scores because we don't want
them pull into critic yeah the AR meta
critic needs a bump up if you could see
they'll convert sweaters to one to 100
and then you can't control
that so you actually get to talk to the
dentist early on he seems a little
Shifty like I feel like he's up to
something I said
scram that actually looks like Tasha
down there that character based on
Tasha yeah so you just go smacking kids
in this whole game right you can smack
them around and you hit cops in the
belly yeah we give the player a moral
choice you
can yeah where you at on the
now the end the game will tell you how
moral you are and you're getting this is
actually one of the environments from
the first game but you leave this pretty
soon as the evil uh scheme becomes
apparent yeah they're kind of prepping
this Halloween block party which is what
set the dentist off in the first place
wait did you just do wheelies in a
pirate costume I did what an amazing
advancement over the first game you can
wheelie are you telling me you can
wheelie in any costume any costume
that's because first of all it's awesome
to wheelie around and everyone uh wanted
to do that in the other costumes yes you
don't it's not part of a robot costume
to have wheels really I'm sure that was
a much requested uh feature from the
community speaking of which if everyone
has any questions in the Gamespot chat
um reply to me on that chat room and
I'll be sure to ask the dudes here watch
it uh oh who's he talking to what is
that character gab that's the
chronoclock oh it's kind wrong with your
face see how that that's good he's got
clock on his face what's your
excuse I didn't know they had Dennis in
chronous land he's got kind of a Flav of
flave
clock so the lawsuit's coming then mhm
he more delicate with
it oh you know the color purple means
magic is that like a design philosophy
you guys have everything doctor told me
to tell people you're
dentist that's a little dainty little
yeah so the krocus doesn't seem to
approve of that so they're going I would
suspect somewhere in time would that be
yes they are traveling through time
backwards or good purposes uh I don't
want to spoil it yeah we don't know yet
we'll find out shortly we're spoiling
the whole start of the game came back
and he stole something from the P future
that looks like the past right there
yeah he went somewhere to get that thing
he went back to Monkey Island 2 Monkey
Island one
sorry doll right that's two that's two
it was two damn it yeah so by grabbing
that thing he's released the uh releas
the
Monsters and he's harmed Halloween in
some way so why does this guy want to
stop candy um he had a repressed
childhood and his mom kept him from
Candy as he grew he's obsessed with
dental hygi well if he removes candy
from the world isn't he basically
putting himself out of work maybe he do
think these things true maybe he's not
being logical okay rarely is the same
way doctors go around causing accidents
ah of course yes makes sense he's
obsessed with clean teeth and he doesn't
like what candy does to
it is that a spoiler that's a spoiler
what's spoiler who's that when he said
something it question mark yeah you
don't know who that guy is oh that's he
had conf Pro though because he went head
first yeah that's confidence in the time
portal that um Dennis I forgot who he
reminds me of the guy who played Steve
Austin's boss and the $6 million man you
guys are all way too young I just
realized I'm all alone here talking
about the $6 Million Man Oscar Goldman
the guy who played Oscar Goldman come on
in 2014 you $6 million it wouldn't be
that impressive a man he can't even make
an Venture inspired partly he was like
half Steve Martin from Little sh of
Horrors and half du Oscar Goldman I'm
someone someone on the internet knows
who Oscar Goldman is or all your viewers
like 14 I'm sure yeah I'm sure all the
the chat is is you be like a $6 Million
Man guy if you were born just a little
bit older maybe what are we talking
was 70 76 70 no not quite ask your dad
missed it by a couple years it's Everett
that's ever from the first game and
Lucy uh we we got some fat questions
coming in don't me throw them out at you
depends what they are H 89 so that
person is definitely 26 or so oh okay is
[__] c a single player only game or does
it have Cooperative or anything just
single player single player massively
single
player mhm but if if it's a huge hit I'm
sure we'll make Us multiplayer win next
yeah that'd be fun Co-op it's a good
point I mean it's a good point it would
be fun as a co-op but uh did you
consider it it wasn't something people
were clammering for yeah they wanted
more uh costumes more stuff from the
first game and a deeper combat system is
the main thing they asked for and so
that's I think what the focus of the
team has been so far you'll see when we
get into the combat that there's more
choices the player can make creepy treat
cards have more functional use and also
the ability to scoot around on and Scot
around on roller skates oh I see some
sort of weird uh what's going on this is
not your I like this this is the
dystopian future is that um is that that
game transistor back there this the
prepost the cop is that what yeah you're
just your s Cav are sharing assets yeah
we're good friends all of us right down
the street game developers to share
assets these are the dental drones to go
around looking for you're missing a
comedy opportunity you should be
chattering Ste should be chattering the
whole time oh
it's all right Kung Fu Crow showed up
this is obviously not called technically
Kung Fu Crow but no his name is CR wher
he's a Crest it's Latin for Kung Fu Crow
do you say Crest Whaler Crest Whaler
what's a Crest Whaler Crest Whaler is a
term for that race of beings in the
first game there trogs grubbins and
Crest Whalers you called them crestw
eyes in Europe sounds fancier though I
like that chis
eyes you guys ever have nightmares about
your
teeth yeah I have this nightmare that I
bite my an apple and they all shatter
like glass yeah is that that is that
that the Apple isn't there but the
shattering and I'm trying to put them
back in oh a real part of it I think
that's a fear of powerlessness is it and
impotence oh no I've never had
that okay so this is the combat Gabe how
is combat different or is that going to
be distracting you if we ask you
question uh combat is a lot different we
kind of rebooted it in the old one you
kind of jumped and in the middle of the
jump there was like a QT te where you
waggle the stick or hit the button a
bunch of times and we wanted it
to uh be a little more engaging and less
button mashy so we moved the timing to
the the hit so you kind of have to time
it with the animation now and every
character has a different timing so it
makes it a little more interesting there
and then we also added uh combos that
you can unlock this guy is sort of your
battle instructor throughout the game so
as you uh level up he'll beckoning you
to come learn new techniques like
tutorial Crow you are real good at
combatting on this he's got an amazing
tutorial Crow was his first name okay
the first time I've played it too oh
really you ran the whole project and you
never yeah I refused to look at it until
it was done that's a good move that's a
good move keeps that fresh what are
those habit trails in the background is
that like crash out
there that's just how the CR wouldn't
let anyone play it even the
testers press w a he's got a lot of
swords and he's just punching and
kicking well he kicked me in your first
time as fill up my special meters
critical eye I can cut some of those
swords just for frame rate oh sweet
Justice seems familiar like there's some
game where I seen that before what was
in that bus candy Oh Oh I thought it was
like I'm also distracted by watching
that billboard back there with a guy
chasing a bunch of horses what was he
chasing Delectables Delectables is a
creepy
treat everyone seems so nonplused by the
time
portals would you want just used to it
now these kids lives have been forever
traumatized by the actions of these
video bad guys are trying to get in have
a Crest wer living in your backyard
one's going to call Crest W now that's
Canon
now now you can see these guys are onto
them trying to break down the
door so got to take the time hole to
take the time hole time hole we got to
get get to that doll before the dentist
does so you're going to go back even
farther than the dentist went we went
back to the
80s what's what's the difference between
' 80s Halloween and current day
Halloween more neon hoverboards right
it's funny you said in the bayou and we
realized that the Bayou did looks the
same in every era yeah so this is the
bou in the 8S it's probably got better
Verizon reception
though and these guys look so adorable
they could possibly be bad right
gabe'll see they look good they're
probably going to be your
friends that was clever having little
pig pen clouds so you don't have to show
their
feet I shouldn't point that stuff
out Trade Secrets yeah Pig Pen clouds
are you like giving him his one-on-one
like his staff appraisal live on the
show yeah like just so in terms of
innovation and uh getting along with
others give you I'll give you as
continual personal give you high three
on that one
on the pig pen Cloud the pig pen Cloud
scale High
three how many costumes are in this one
then hey there's an alligator uh there
are 11 there were four pre-order
costumes as well that were from the
first game but in this game you also get
to upgrade your costumes so you can uh
buy stuff from the shop that will change
the look of them and also kind of beat
them up a little bit not buy them with
in that purchases but buy them in you
can in the shop with game currency not
real currency what if somebody just
wanted to put a check in the mail are
you going to
stop I can do
that I was like why did I think of that
now that candy corn seems to be a really
effective
costume yeah the Candy Corn is sort of a
meat Shield like a tank corn Shield is
he is he like the teddy bear in
EarthBound is it the teddy bear or the
dog or they the dog or was it no one of
the characters one of the people your
party doesn't have a doesn't fight for a
while does he the dog I think prayed or
something like that when you fought and
then during the boss battle he had this
thing that came out I would say the main
difference between the two games the
water is really beautiful in C Quest too
see that water that was amazing this
Unreal Engine three no this is the uh
Buddha
engine Buddha is the coding for the
engine that started with uh look at that
water look at the sleeping
alligator you have attack the
alligators is there that does
that it's coming to Tim sh for post
relase patch yeah whenever you're doing
a demo think talk about things that
aren't in the game yeah like when
whenever you're doing an interview about
games ask about DLC because that's what
everyone's already asking you guys going
to do DLC this time
around
uh costumes are DLC really the pre-order
ones yeah you pick them up wait you
can't they're only for pre-order you
can't yeah yeah we don't have any
postlaunch DLC not yet am all right
right right yeah depends how many copies
you buy that I know
of at Bulba babe 1986 Bulba Bulba babe
I'm going to guess that is a girl who's
28 years old who likes Bulbasaur will it
sport generic controllers uh will there
be sport for dual shock 4 as well as the
Xbox SL so on PC on PC yeah just support
controllers I assume that just general
yeah yeah we've been supporting
controllers on this engine for a while
so I'm sure got pretty broad controller
support liac wants to know you guys
going to make any more seasonal games
apart from Costume Quest always talked
about let's make Christmas Christmas
Quest it was more in case we slip the
schedule and we miss Halloween let's
let's let's reboot this as a um just
find and replace all the purple with red
and green and be fun mhm now is this the
part where a clown has been eaten by bun
alligators is that what's Happening Here
G uh this kid runs a alligator farm and
they ripped apart his costume bit weird
but not an actual living clown no is
that a normal thing in America in the
body you the children R Gator Farms oh
yeah yeah oh yeah we all did that's
typical
mhm clown it's a sweet costume it's not
a scary clown though is it it's a happy
clown it's kind of redundant scary clown
is it is this booze back here yeah hard
liquor moonshine it's the only way I can
get through these interviews they're
pretty stressful yeah now Monty Monte is
the name of your friend from the bio
yeah is Monty a bio you kind of name
that sounds kind of like an
Englishman trying to bring up England
again just cuz it always pisses
off maybe he's a
transient alligator's in the way okay
what are you doing you switch to clown
costume I'm going to honk him you ready
H honk that alligator oh never this is
teaching good skills to kids yeah yeah
if you ever meet an alligator don't
worry if you have a clown costume these
are based on life experiences oh that's
scary that's obviously one of the guys
from the Warriors baseball Fury that's
little
bones uh jimu in the chat says appar in
the 80s Halloween had a lot more razor
blades in the candy you know
there's are there a lot of razor blades
in the candy I always heard about that
when I was a kid but I never ate one I
heard there's never been a case this fun
there's never been a case of Halloween
candy poisoning that wasn't traced back
to the kids's own family we didn't oh
that's way darker that's the worst fun
fact in the world yeah I like that
halfway through
but there's been loads of those ones
like all the time I don't know the
actual numbers we didn't have Snopes
back then okay pre Snopes nothing is
known before
Snopes oh is this going to be good or
bad is this your first
trick-or-treating oh good oh she's got
something she's got one of those Humpty
noses sweet sweet kind hump is that is
that is that before your time too like 6
Humpty Hump totally tot Humpty Hump
what's Humpty Hump
let's cut to that right now this could
be an age thing or it could be a
geographical thing it's it's it's your
chance to do the this Digital
Underground like Humpty Dumpty the
Humpty Dance she should point out the
fact that she's having a baby something
you should mention oh yeah yeah not just
that you just routinely is that what
you're referring to yeah that is the
character yes that's your chance to do
the hum got he wears a a big fake nose I
mean I hope it's fake and not some sort
it was like a Gro nose
different though without a mustache look
at that look at the time and energy you
put into having two different superhero
cost one the for the girls yeah hey did
you know we're giving away copies of
Costume Quest 2 right here on this video
game in live stream you can't you don't
you don't just get to watch it being
played you could you could actually with
your hands you could using the power of
social media you could win a copy of
this video game surely for like a
million
dollars setting you up to say it's free
sorry no it's free you don't even have
to pay a million dollars all you have to
do is follow Gamespot on the Twitter and
then retweet that thing we done tweeted
before when the show started it that's
like two clicks you just
follow gam spot Gamespot video games on
Twitter you might win a copy and you
might win a copy all right here's the
clown special he's a Healer obviously
terrifying it's scary clown scary clown
and what's his power
called what a
joker
laughter is the best medicine laughter
is the best medicine and it you healed
everybody so what are those little icons
next to the health barers
okay those are Port gun the kids no not
those types the character the character
types oh oh oh
on when you're on offense so each
costume so if you look at the enemies
there's a little like set of teeth those
are Monster types and then you can see
that Ren has uh a green and a red sign
is sort of like their uh resistance I
guess to the uh to those types so she's
strong against magic and weak against
monster so what are the classes is like
magic monster Tech and Tech so each
costume is it each character each
costume each cost costume is good
against one and weak against another so
you actually have to think about what
costume you're putting on before you go
into battle and uh who have to think
about what order to attack in so you're
not just button mashing through your
your guys should you always bring candy
corn um well if you want to get the hard
corn mode achievement yeah hard corn
hard corn yeah great it's basically
taking one of your attackers out so it's
a lot harder to play with it so he takes
damage well the way to to add challenge
to the game to get the hardcore
achievement you have to play the entire
game with yeah in your underwear in your
party you you can't accidentally swap
out that costume where you lose the
achievement yeah that is pretty hardcore
I didn't know what what what candy corn
was until I played costume c one really
it's not like a thing in Europe we don't
have it just like we don't denst
Philadelphia it's what it was invented
in Philadelphia is that true did you do
some research on candy corn did you have
to get sign off from Philadelphia candy
corn
lines so did a lot of research is there
anything you don't know about candy corn
it's made out of like horse hoes right
it's made out of wax there's wax in
there what wax and high fructose corn s
first I find out wasps and figs and now
there all figs I mean that's all figs is
it like a percentage of a l crunch part
it's like part of the actual creation
method yeah now I feel like I'm stepping
on GI bom to the Fig wasp helps
fertilize the the plant yeah right did
you learn that on the circle of life
that's the kind of science show that is
Hardcore science so you can't eat a fig
without a was science yes exactly you're
going to have a wasp's child if you need
a f a wi angle I just got a creepy treat
card oh my gosh what are those
and you LEL up and I leveled up it was
that was a moment thing so in the
notebook you have these creepy treat
cards which you can equip in your deck
over here which it automatically did for
me and then I can play these in battle
to have different effects there's 45
different uh creepy treat cards I like
that picture of a guy eating ghosts yeah
did a good job this is this a good spot
to to leave it for the the folks at home
to play the rest of the game sure no
we're play the whole thing we play the
whole thing here
Marathon it saves me the trouble of
playing it if I could just sit here and
watch game play really it's more
efficient just give it a week and then
twitch will have speed runs already up
that's awesome that's costume 2 it's day
it's really good is it really good
really good as an objective beautiful
viewer well I didn't make it Gabe and
his team made it that's true I could say
I mean it's no Broken Age but it's great
in its own way speaking of all the other
games you guys are working on uh when's
what's the story with grim oh Grim yeah
grim just uh we are what's the official
name Grim Fango remastered Grio
remastered okay we're seeing it as like
we're making like a Blu-ray of
kasablanca we're not re-shooting you
literally took the line that was in your
double fine Productions video cuz I
watched it to get all my lines I was
like oh here's what we're going to say
your Criterion Collection yeahand said I
think it I think it made sense because
like some people thought we were going
to remake the game from scratch I was
like that game is fine and like I said
better than Casablanca so
essentially that's not too much to say
Casablanca is ask your dad about them
this is how I treat Brad Mir in the
office every day all Brad because he
like doesn't know who Fonzi is like
explain but you guys are doing stuff
like uh the like there are 3D models for
the characters now like there's new
lighting new new lighting um um path for
it and uh we're Uprising the textures
repainting them still fourth you doing
because um it was all storyboarded
really carefully to be in that aspect
right to make sure what is viewable and
what's not viable and so we didn't want
to mess with that but we probably do
different modes of we want to find a way
of of of using more of the screen but
we're still experimenting with that CU
in when you HD did the HD re-releases of
uh the secret of Monkey Island I just
realized you're saying HD HD H H it
sounds like hate h yeah HD when you okay
go on it's in English all that Dental
Care he didn't get
exactly last time I get you Myer pretty
good let me see your teeth let have a
teeth off it's good thing bra is not
here he does have amazing teeth do you
guys have good deal plan and double fun
yeah you got full courage exactly you
guys making a bunch of games ining well
this one not this is part of the
partnership program you guys have this
is double presents are we talking about
gang be now yeah yeah uh by bone loaf by
bone Loaf a lovely set of three brothers
and one non brother and they of the UK
Sheffield Sheffield cool wow you got all
the facts I hung out with them during
packs yeah yeah yeah they're hilarious
and they basically are like this beating
each other up yeah just beating each
other up you can tell the games made by
brothers and we have you here not just
to talk about it but to play as well I
don't think that's one of them is it it
is all right cool yeah how many players
four four yeah let's uh let's try it out
uh yeah so Brad apparently you are the
the current reigning champion of uh
perhaps uh the qued one oh yeah yeah
wait I don't like playing people who are
good perhaps self-proclaimed but yeah
sure yeah well Vinnie carv doesn't seem
too happy about this I said on Twitter
and he was if he's if he wants to come
back and defend his supposed title he's
welcome to do so uh what stage you want
to do all of them what's your favorite
how else do you play Gang Beast random
ooh random yeah let's random
okay where we going where we going oh
yeah R generator is good like say just
start start the wheel that's good five
three yeah four three
three start all right what wait how we
start oh this is the okay okay I press y
to see who I am I'm yellow which I think
I'm a blue chicken I'm the Dragon I'm
the bear it's on you're blue chicken
you're green bear no red guy red guy all
right I'm going to stay up here this is
like double F versus videogames.com
versus giant
bomb oops I dropped him I got no no no
no F and Conquer yeah that's right
coming with me shaer yes you still
holding on oh this is I fell to my death
somehow I like it you're um I think I
turned off arm strength anyway okay
we're just down to the wait how does
that work
what the arm strength yeah you can turn
it on and off so that you can like if
you're holding on too long it'll make
you I think it's good especially for
this level you can get uh oh boy you
don't want to end up in an infinite hang
later go
bear no arm see arm you have arm enough
you can go all the way around my
favorite way to win by default H we were
playing a couple weeks ago I think I
thought you kill anybody I was stuck in
the thing I was off camera it's not
about killing it's about surviving oh
boy and then kill my favorite thing is
to hide so no more infinite hang is what
you're saying you just fall off again I
couldn't get back on Wow Vinnie caraval
is watching this and gritting his teeth
I bet his beautiful
teeth give here gab oh wait no I got you
Noe I'm going no you guys sorted out
between yourselves this is uh-oh I
died I'm sucking you
out God damn it half blue and half
white no no not again yeah no no sh [__]
what a off the plank
I can't believe you won
Pikachu look you crying in Joy fall down
I can't believe I won you
inviting law copyright infringement
claims am I out cuz I lost twice you out
already oh there I am no no I'm
fine yep I heard that one what was I
doing I was off screen and I just fell
to my death out of nowhere H we played
this a couple weeks ago and one of the
guys had a sombrero on and got like
stuck between the planks yep the SoMo is
a tactical uh tactical somy tactical
SoMo is a good name
for oh there I amh no no how are you
holding
in I'm yellow R you're green right yes
okay no you
maybe they died three times I would
fight so again to confirm I cannot hang
forever no okay it's going to cause me
some problems screaming yes in the back
of no no oh this is it it's like the end
fight of the Matrix mhm with drunk
cosplaying babies you go down you go
mhm God damn it get away from me oh he's
grabbing you in the worst Way's got one
that's right fall fall one on your hand
and one on your
kidney is that MLG down you go style
Gang Beast I got you by the ear no yes
yes yes yes yes stay up oh my
god oh
man one more made it yeah one more oh
Subway this could last forever yeah oh
please why did you guys take the ramp
out oh no you didn't make it but why did
they take the ramp out which ramp there
was a ramp in the AL oh you're right
they did yeah yeah back up they want
there there's a way to kind of jump if
you grab jump and then you let go and
you grab again you can kind of like pull
yourself up that's Advanced uh so Gabe
one thing if you're on the right you die
last oh I forgot how to oh [__] I forgot
how to climb how do you climb again you
know you grab and you jump and let go I
don't think it
matters I'm not Esports enough to to
climb are you guys bringing this to EO
is somebody still alive tring to
par I want to know if you
guys I thought I could get you by hiding
hiding is my favorite thing in crafty
shaer are you guys going to I want to
know if you're going to add a like Royal
Rumble mode to this oh man use at the
next packs panel yeah I'm still bitter
about not getting invited this same here
man you didn't I'm going to boycott that
thing even though they never invited
me what's
that Greg rice
off oh that'd be so good I mean this is
this is truly the best wrestling game
ever made next time
for camera no
no oh come on oh no no no no no no no no
I'm too young don't you
pretty that's the cffs oh this is good
yes really can't okay where do I push
the button for the train You' got two
trains push where does that escalator go
nowhere let go see I can't remember how
to climb you can do it you climbed up
like I know but that was that was like a
month ago oh look I'm doing it you're
climbing up
the uh uh you're making here let me off
you my hand let me off you my hand you
should have listened to
me died in my arms in the railroad
track I mention this game's available on
Steam right now it's an early
access I forgot what color I am I'm
Pikachu I'm emboldened by my victory
wait did I just die why did I just fell
over for no reason there go throw
traffic to somebody there you go there
you go get out there no stop struggling
struggling just makes it
harder
aha no no
oh what are you doing no no I'm trying
to do some some Parkour not parkour
what's the ground dancing what's the
dancing fighting thing c
c nobody in these room there's
no there's nobody in these rooms come
back here oh wait that door's open come
back here this is that's a good hiding
place this reminds me of the I'm going
to beat you open body is still down
there just dead with this
cone is is this a working elevator wait
is that a rampo there the elevator does
work the elevator took a long oh no no
no no
no give him a hand Gabe I wasn't
thinking straight help me up how do you
you just doing this good little
move oh this train will fix things hold
on oh oh you almost got it oh that's the
worst way too cuz if you run over you're
dead but you were just kind of like
ground around the
edge like rolled like a little Play-Doh
snake how much time did the uh
development team spending the London
undergrounds doing research for this
every day every day oops this kind of
looks like Shepherd's Bush at about 1:
in the morning what who's shepher
Shepherd get away get away I'm going to
have to remember how to climb if I'm
going to defend my
title can't just climb up anywhere oh
wait that's not that's not regation
there's there's some Nuance to it that I
can't remember there's Nuance Gang
Beasts it is well you have to hold on
then you have to let go jump and grab
again again
right no oh I think I just
remembered yep are you doing are you
doing it different arms get down here
yeah get down get down here ready to
tangle oh now you're so tough you can
climb a wall wall no how' you guys get
hooked up with bone loaf anyway we
partnership come about I believe Greg
didn't they mail in the uh Indies and
double Vine oh really they did yeah
we yeah we our first presents game was a
skateb 2 which is awesome yeah we have
on the show our first ever show I think
that was a lot of
fun and your first ever show as our
first ever dou presents and then oh um
[__] I don't know if last life or
Mountain came
next last life a Kickstarter for an
adventure game that was in production
down there quit City Metro last life and
then uh Mountain David O'Reilly's uh
game at the with the mountain in it I
not mountain and and then these guys
mailed us and we're like let's check
this game out and then we started
laughing and playing immediately I mean
it's not it's not a game that takes too
much time before everyone's just like oh
that looks so violent oh I'm always just
taken with the kind of adorable level of
violence that it has you know what I
mean like it's oh no don't don't mess up
for me this was always going to happen
I'll just casually walk to the right of
you and I think they'll be
fine why is this not working
anymore why did you have to turn off the
go to the right of him that's not get to
that point how did he get past that
point that's not really going to help
like up like this oh maybe why hump the
wall yeah but it's it no no no no no no
no no no no no no oh what just happened
killed yourselves did we walk into a
death thing all right oh who's in the
final not
me oh it's team double F come here
dragon come here you little come here
you little don't even I float like a
butterfly you're just running like a
chicken come on you're running like a
chicken I'm running like a
dragon no no no no Okay no Okay jump
grab kick jump wait jump grab y down
down ybx bone loaf help me out quick
mail me mail me the answer tell me how
to climb a
wall I know there's a way see it's a
deep game you you should just it's easy
to pick up and play but there's these
really complicated climbing thing you're
still learning Lear still learning the
depth of this game and the Mastery Gang
Beasts made by available now do you guys
do you have any mortal tidbits about
what to expect in the next update mortal
tidbits yeah I don't I know some of
their their plans about the um how where
they're going with a single player
campaign of it I'm just something dirty
was happening on the screen um I don't
know the exact next update where the
next feature is do you know Greg yeah
Greg knows just broke come on Greg come
on you get out my mic cuz I don't know
when the next update is
speaking hi I don't know I think I'm on
here hi guys hey Gang Beast yeah what's
happening in Gang Beast uh yeah I don't
know exactly what the next update is
like that's why we called you over but I
do no plans so uh yeah there's like uh
there's a single player co-op mode which
is kind of like Streets of Rage style uh
double dragon against AI so that's
coming and then lots and lots of maps
and modes and things like that um yeah
so thanks be fun lots of punching and
kicking up I was did I win for you I
think I won I was I was looking good job
I think I
won H we got a bunch of people who won
copies of Costume Quest to Tim could you
could you do us the honors okay I hope
none of these are dirty these are all
people watching on
gamespot.com at Omega nightmare sure is
that omegan is it like Megan omegan
nightmare if it is it's really omegan
nightmare okay no no feel free to
analyze every one of them rain one is
that like rore one klar klar dat
someone's in here editing this document
this is creepy uh data cat data cats
that sounds like a company I think that
was just a plug for a company
De
d samr d
Mano one of these is kind do you get a
lot of like OB XX nuto
420 like my huge whatever my yeah my
James
Knack deage
deage rival child Spirit of jazz with
three Z's and then someone's just typing
dirty words in here yeah great balls
deep also won a copy wonderful balls
Yeah Tim schaer have to give balls deep
gab maer thank you very much for coming
on really appreciate
it yeah and bra thank you for coming on
as well wait wait didn't who won CU
you're the Undisputed I won the first
one right champion who won that little
round we were playing with nonstandard
rules I kind of remember it as me
winning I wasn't really paying too close
attention I kind of had this feeling
that I want in terms of most death by
train you nailed it absolutely perfect I
think that was hardcoded into the game
okay yeah if Tim schaer than then death
by train H thanks P for coming on uh
Vinnie is coming on next time because
you suck at candies fine we got more
stuff coming up on the lobby today uh
we're going to check out alien isolon H
in just a couple minutes but first of
all Drive Club review went up today
Kevin gave it 5 out of 10 so we talked
to him for a couple minutes and asked
him what he thought about that racing
ass video game back in a few say racing
I don't know do you like do you even do
you even like racing games I guess
that's what I'm asking I love racing
games actually this a silly what are you
asking me this question for are you a
commenter I'm sorry you are you one of
those people so me and Andy played a
bunch of Drive Club yesterday on the
stream and uh in like the the and I
played a bunch over the weekend as well
and in like the couple of hours exposure
I had to it I was like this is a really
basic driving game yeah I feel like
we're all kind of on the same page with
this game right uh which is really weird
because of course you know the the
critical reactions have been very very
wide I was kind of surprised by that
when I woke up this morning yeah but I
mean all all in all I think my drive
Club experience was you know I I I sort
of said it in the review I just like
well this game exists if there's a if
there's a game that argues for objective
game reviews it's this one because it's
like well you get pretty cars and you
drive in really pretty places and then
you go vroom until you get to the end
and then you're given a time and
sometimes you you're uh you're raided
against people that are in your drive
club or strangers or people in other
drive clubs and that's sort of the game
yeah that's sort of the game I was
really surprised by that the progression
stuff was just so incredibly linear it
was like you just unlock cars there's no
modification of the cars you can't even
do like any modification in terms of how
they handle you can't pick what cars you
unlock you can't pick what like races
you unlock or any of that it's just keep
playing keep getting Stars unlock stuff
add nauseum and then like we put it on
professional to see if the AI
reacted what was it we said that they
had the AI from the noia snake game
because the cars just do that like they
just swim in a line behind each other
yeah the AI is really big into sticking
to the racing line no matter what
they'll just drive as fast as they can
down the r facing line regardless of
what vehicle they're in regardless of
where you are so you get bumped a lot um
they'll collide with you or they'll
Collide from the side or whatever and
what will happen is sometimes that'll
send you caring into the car in front of
you and the game will punish you for a
collision or for not taking a corner
properly so if it if it thinks that
you're causing an accident or if it
thinks that you're trying to take a
shortcut you get a penalty and what it
does is it lowers your maximum speed for
like you can't accelerate for for like 3
seconds or something like that it's it's
sort of weird that the game is the
driest driving game it's it's the
blandest club that ever blanded a bland
yeah the clubs only have six people by
the way so my club is already full yeah
six people in drive clubs well thank I
think uh yeah for for any more details
on the on Drive Club you could you could
check out the review on
gamespot.com them video
games
draft Club sup Kevin I'm confused dra
club I'm why didn't we just do this now
why y'all came around to talk to me and
I'm like I'm just going to be here I'm
sitting right here because we talked to
you for 15 minutes and we' edit it down
cuz you're all like y y y y y pretty
yappy it's true you get me going and I
just like did you play a new Drive Club
CH negative no not a lick I did I played
a bit you did we to stream we did
yesterday um where we broke hella
embargos and then just re-recorded it
for the side sweet yeah um yeah you had
the Embargo sheet up and you're like
using that as a list of things to do
yeah kind of that doesn't seem like a
good tactic it says show all these
things show the weird thing was they
actually only wanted us to play with the
like super cars and Hyper cars and me
and Andy played all weekend with like
the hot hatches and all the like regular
cars ones that have like really it's
like a Toyota Corolla and you're like oh
they soup it up for race tuning and
you're like well see this parked in my
garage apartment in my but it's like way
easier to go around all these Mountain
Trails on it so then when we were let
loose with the with the hyper car yeah
and there's nothing worse than like we
practiced all weekend because for racing
games specifically like yeah you want
look good you want to be able to cuz
like racing game fans are the most
critical when it comes to like you
playing and like you suck at racing
games why don't you want automatic and
man Kevin does sound exactly like that
yeah that's kind of what I do
yeah no that game is interesting but not
ultimately uh not ultimately great can
you answer a question for me though
what's the difference between a super
and a hyper car oh like so supercars
used to be the Pinnacle of there's
probably a horsepower requirement but
like hypercars are the ones where they
only make like five of them okay and
they they're like are only ever
displayed in museums or something yeah
I'm not sure street legal maybe yeah
they're not street legal they can hover
a little bit they synthesize food on the
dashboard well and then they drink a lot
of that's kind of the hyper part they've
got flux Capac yeah you you you you pour
some caffeine into the tank and and cuz
pure caffeine is that how it's done
that's not Kevin and I have a great
understanding of Motor Vehicles and
science well we've talked enough bed
Drive Club all right we've done enough
padding to make sure alien isol we're
working on this because we have a little
technical problem which is why we're
we're talking about nothing at all so so
I had a save all set to go and now it
looks like um somebody did a a start at
the beginning thing autod death scale
form so
oh yeah hav up in up in this but but I
feel like like the problem with these
games like scary games is that when you
play them like during the day it's not
scary enough so we should bring in like
some some you want to play it at night
yeah at night time yeah when it's like
dark yeah keep going keep going oh yeah
there you go oh god oh oh Jes this is
going to freak me out isn't it blinding
I'm so I'm hoping this is the save I
want it to be because look like there
was
some some save um manipulation going on
but so I know if I'm in the right in the
place I wanted to be or not it says
flamethrower on the screen so I'm pretty
sure you're in the right place okay I'm
bringing this slide in closer here let's
oh God what are you doing to me mood
lighting this is are you trying to like
make me freak out here we go oh God this
is very difficult yeah this is this is
aggressively worse than normal play situ
I can see for
sure all right let's see what's going on
here but it looks hell of cool I mean
look at yourself in the PIP Kevin hi hi
we look we look pretty awesome so I
don't I don't I don't know where I am in
the game now so uh I'll just continue is
that your best scary
face alien isolation Jes CHR it's not
even the visual it was the movement
thing got him oh I know where I am okay
scratch it I love this lighting one of
the things before we started this was
that folks were worried that we we do
the demo uh I'm not see the alien like
no I have this this is since this is a
place we'll see the alien in fact if I
need to I'll purposefully die just so we
can see alien death but you you don't
see the alien that often right well the
the aliens relatively rare All Things
Considered most levels do not feature
the alien so are there like alien heavy
bits and then the rest there are alien
heavy bits versus bits that are not
alien
heavy would you say the game is not
alien heavy enough or it's too alien
heavy I would say that it's not alien
heavy enough that's the thing the game
does best and for me at least I felt
like there was a lot of
and I need a med kit badly need to like
needs to like go on the paleo diet for
all the syn synthetic stuff I see what
you did there actually some of the
synthetic stuff is pretty cool though
but they're but they're they're like a
prepared enemy and anything you
cultivate or prepare you can't have in
paleo you just need rob you should
really stop talking about this have you
ever done the Paleo thing no I did it
once yeah yeah eat a lot of sausage
andet I thought that was that's cost a
lot of money grass beef all the time
like that ain't cheap you can't Pat out
meals with grains or rice can you use
rice uh no but like any kind of yeah
like bread all that stuff yeah like no
carb it's pretty delicious but it's
pretty uh so hopefully this will avoid
spoilers but the game's been out a week
so I don't think there are any cut
scenes or anything coming up though
spoilers there are aliens and also other
things trying to kill you flamethrower
doesn't come until later um in the game
so this is not something that you have
your first Alien Encounter but in
basically your second big alien uh bit
so you were just with like a sense cuz
the flamethrower doesn't really Factor
until the second alien movie
right I see what you did there film
knowledge so earlier on there was a
bunch of like human allies so what are
you allies what are you doing at the
moment that's like so right now we're
basically trying to trap the alien um so
that we can basically jettison it into
into space but are you with those people
a lot no well you do sometimes you run
into friendlies um more often you run
into non-f friendlies so the people that
what oh my God I need to tweet a picture
of what the setup actually looks like so
that people can see and one thing you
don't want to do is have the motion
tracker going all the time because it
actually makes noise oh really yeah so
they will you know you can you can give
yourself away if you have the alien
tracker out all the time or the motion
tracker out all the the time is it scary
I when I did survivor mode I was really
on edge quite a lot this this game can
be quite scary other times it can just
be
like right but when the aliens around it
can be really terrifying so what were
your sort of main criticisms of it then
well one of the one of the things was
the filler it's like uh I mean depending
on how long you played it took me about
16 hours but I heard of people spending
like 20 hours on it and for me a lot of
that stuff's just Meandering and which
is great except that it's not always
building tension when it does that
sometimes it's just walking right and it
yeah enough where it's like wow I've
been doing this a while and the thing is
like when you do stuff like this you so
you you you know you build up some you
know some information on the story and
lots of references to you know alien
stuff says like you didn't read a lot of
it well I've already seen this a million
times so I don't want to like I don't
want this to be all just um I think he's
referring to your uh the reference you
made to the lore as alien oh right well
alien so I'm going to save my game um
it'll tell you if there are aliens
nearby do you have enough ink ribbons to
save right now that's yeah you don't
need ink ribbons it's it's uh although
you have to be careful like you you
really do need to like look at this map
occasionally to make to know where those
safe spots are because sometimes you
want to really get to a save spot um
because you can lose a lot of progress
is there much repetition of like like
backtracking and stuff there's a lot
there's quite a bit of backtracking not
early on but when you first start you
see all these doors that you can't go
through and like you don't have the tool
for that or the power is not on for that
okay so I almost missed it cuz oh Jesus
Christ what is that guy so that's a
that's a synthetic so the synthetics are
a problem AB aboard the sasta pole so
you are Ellen Ripley's Daughter by the
way Amanda in this game and um there's
definitely stuff going on with the
synthetics um bad stuff but poor
situational awareness well yeah Amanda's
just super stealthy he's fine right now
can you you can't just go up and press X
to stop him in the back well you can get
him but he won't die he won't just go
down oh oh God it's creepy with his
eyeballs oh he got like meture solid one
cone of vision where he can't see
something 15t in front of him but 14 ft
you are boned so this is what I get for
uh see the other thing is if you start
making too much noise and the alien
comes out oh I can hear
it oh is that behind the wall it's hard
to tell cuz you can't you can't oh [__]
there it is there it is I'm done I'm
done there he is you are so dead oh my
goodness and so so we we uh we go back
again do that bit again so that's that's
the scary stuff like but this is It's
really scary if you're inside like a
like a locker so if you had if you
hadn't have saved there your apartment
can't be that I'd have to go back to the
original really there are only there are
like a couple places only where there's
an autosave and it's always after like
major story things kill that try and
kill that guy there you really want that
yeah because you I might die yeah but
you reloaded anyway you just died
anyways true all right I'll try
synthetic is that oh did you just Club
him with your
revolver and then shoot him in the
trapezius muscles so I guess you shot
him through the throat EMP mine oh
[__] that's uh so this will be a quick
time event is he choking you are you
quick enough want the
flamethrower oh that's freak
oh oh that was good are you still alive
so I survived because you scare the
alien with the Flames wow it's not gone
forever can you scare the alien with
folk music there was a no there is a
guitar there though starts strumming
some cash and the alien just Mellows out
so now I'm like really scared to death
um because I have no life there it is oh
he's he went up into the thing okay
thank God you got him on the Run oh I
think I hear it behind you
again oh you'll always hear that noise
and freak the [__]
out like the sound design in this game
is seriously creepy when it comes to the
alien and now I'm scared to death how
you not whenever you hear that just like
wildly looking around at everything well
first of all the game's camera doesn't
allow for that oh okay wait that's the
first person this is really this is as
quick as it gets oh okay fair enough on
purpose you can't exactly wildly oh [__]
did it not see you it didn't see me
close your eyes it can't see
you are you just peeping at its butt now
yeah I'm peeping at its butt Sometimes
the best way is to kind of like follow
it to wherever it's going ah don't
duding it doesn't yeah it's it's to work
it's animated so well it's it is look at
the TA dude it's going to see
you and if
you okay I think it went up into the
ceiling oh oh [__] you God damn it Chris
literally whenever you do that no I did
that on purpose to freak him out I did
the darting motion to freak him out
luckily we haven't
seen this is a dead end up here I think
luckily we haven't seen um the alien
ever so often the alien AI either breaks
or does something that kind of cheats um
you actually see a bit of that in the
video review wall hacks um where
basically um uh spawns like despawns and
spawns oh really um using your P I know
I know the the the guy at IGN that
reviewed it had that happen quite a
number of times which can be really
annoying if you're an event and suddenly
it just like spawns runs into the vent
oh
[__] it's really tall you got to you got
to time it right you got to time it
right
no
[__] okay oh God jeez Kevin but I'm not
going to run because when you run you
just draw it out dude look how much
health you have I know and I have no
medkits that I can make eat your
flamethrower for sweet Health by the way
these are little bits of the map if you
come AC cross these you can update your
map before and here's what I was looking
for that was weird earlier cuz you like
I thought you were shutting off the
light on that panel but it I read that
it said update map I was like oh he's
turning off the lights so the alien
can't see him as well but that probably
doesn't make sense alien can probably
see real good okay future GPS doesn't
make sense oh you going to get some
glimmer future you do have a flashlight
I don't actually run into many issue
like many many circumstances where the
flashlight was really important oh yeah
it seems like a really good way of being
like I'm over here I'm scared flashlight
[__] to death where is it see I'm always
afraid of the motion tracker when I know
it's near because it'll just draw it
near just do that like so that like Ping
that are like kind of hard and oh God
you're in the total dark right
now hang on I have to refresh my
batteries this is the worst can I not do
it inside oh there we go okay you're
good you're good okay oh I hope he's not
there oh he's just going to be and the
sound these things make is almost creepy
in and of itself don't have that light
Mak me very nervous okay you're good
you're good can you get the Hello Kitty
flashlight like in Doom three so that
was that was like a really quick just
little passage
so that are much more yeah I sort of
tend to think of like air duct passages
and stuff as a little more elaborate
than just kind of like moving into a
hallway and like like you basically just
turned a corner but you did it inside of
the air duct it seems like sort
of environmental you know like making
those small and like more
numerous gives you more does it give you
more options for how to evade the alien
or places to hide like a a lot of the
time but you always have to make sure to
to note because like oh [__] get back in
the in the jeffy's CH but I don't want
to
run well I was thinking about going back
to the uh Locker to the locker yeah like
I guess in lots of games the air ducts
are just almost like like loading
screens between big areas where in this
it's kind of like a I think it's behind
this door like he's there and I'm going
to kind of ducking yeah you're ducking
ducking out a little bit but you're
still like right there okay I did one in
when me and Ryan played the what was it
called the survivor mode uh I hit in one
of those air ducks and then I saw it
walk past and then I went to get out and
as I did it like just before I got to
the door it opened up on its own and the
alien was right there and just went God
it was pretty awful that is pretty
terrifying okay it's all good it's all
good you're we're all fine we're why do
we think why on Earth would you think
that you were all fine we're all good
we're fine Hassan in the chat is asking
is there any sort of story or character
interactions in this game oh yeah oh
yeah there's there's story and
interactions the story I wouldn't say is
all that and a bag of chips or anything
oh [__] this it's it's where you make
your own story pretty quick yeah the
alien moves really fast
sometimes okay we're
good
I'm going back downstairs Famous Last
Words Get getting the flamethrower when
it stop that stop that stop that this is
helping you succeeded Video Game Stop
that the perspective makes it look like
I'm licking your face why did you cut to
this one now I look like a
creep stop that oh you definitely didn't
look like a creep before did I come down
here before I don't think I think this
is a dead end here but stop that what a
I'm just laughing at
Danny there
yep lights are fun this is how we break
the tension though through humor and
silly
faces I break the tension with the
flamethrowers nice you do have a lot of
flame to throw it seems oh I didn't oh
hello that's the dead dude oh no I did
get him before CHR is this is this more
your Halloween type of game or are you
more of a Costume Quest Halloween game
person oh way more of Costume Quest kind
of dude you know me in scary games man
Chris doesn't do scary games no they
can't they're not happening I mean I've
played the games that have creeped me
out that I've managed to play through
Eternal Darkness Resident Evil scary
yeah I don't know I don't know I feel
like this one would be too good too good
at scaring the jump scares I don't know
I teally play games at night too to
relax but I play like competitive
multiplayer games sometimes to do that
it seems counterintuitive so who knows
maybe this Halloween I'll get get the
Stones up to uh give one of these a try
which do you think should it be this one
Kevin or should it be like dead space
Oh yeah this looks not as scary as like
dead dead space one and two freaked me
out is it over is it in there is it hang
on okay yeah where did this rank in in
like your personal scary I think dead oh
I'm
sorry talking to you are you talking
about pure scares or talking about like
overall game quality I guess that's no
scares like in terms of like scariness
like this in Dead Space Kevin oh would
say that this is
probably oh God I don't know I would say
that dead space was consistently
freakier and scarier okay but I'd say
that this game's individual moments when
it is scary are scary than dead space's
individual moments does that make sense
yes this is is consistently scary but
when it is scary it's you can read all
of Kevin's scariness breakdown on
gamespot.com I also like I I feel a
little more comfortable in the alien
Universe having watched all the movies I
I enjoy those movies uh and I feel like
the as long it's not like sustained
highl dread that's what really messes
with me so that's that's dead space in a
nutshell okay yeah maybe I'll give this
one try I feel like you should uh play
like Allan Wake which is more about
Creepy than like outright or like
Supernatural like weirdnesses more than
like Eternal
Darkness weird stuff yeah but you did
alone in the alone in the dark oh [__]
move this woman who is totally
unperturbed do those people ever get
killed well obviously that person did
but people will get killed you'll see
the alien kill others when you play but
you have to be careful because if you
kill like sometimes you can't really
tell if a human is going to be
um good or bad like because there are a
lot of humans freaking out and like just
shooting everything so you have to be
really careful can you end up killing
the by accident oh is it over there yes
could you tell by the way that I said in
a very manly and calm voice oh there it
is oh it is over
there I feel like the alien is around
all of the time like it's just hang on
hang on
yeah I'm coming under
here hang on hang on is it close I'm
afraid to pull out the motion tracker
and get myself away freaky God he's
right there this is freaky I don't like
it he is right there he is right there
right there
stop
it what somebody came and touched me on
the shoulder I'm not doing anything
Kevin it wasn't oh stop
it Kevin turn around God damn
you I hate all of you I ha all of you
it's a little fun
hey that's exhausting is he in isolation
you can read the full review on on
gamespot.com yeah totally Mr Kevin VOR
totally can we get like a Vincent Price
version of
that read the full review on
gamespot.com I only know Vincent Price
because of The Simpsons when was on that
one I I know because of H Sesame Street
and then a bunch of people know him from
Michael Jackson like in Thriller from
Michael Jackson because he just used to
always hang out with Michael Jackson he
was Vincent twice Vincent twice Vincent
twice Vincent twice he said his name
twice I say twice
no
Ines was the parody like the count yes
can we embarrass Eric T and just make
him walk out now you all right Eric yeah
just get out of yeah do good work Eric
Tay doing God's work you really
shouldn't walk around a set with a
[__] alien mask on you're going to
hit can you just adjust the focus on
that camera real quick with the alien
mask on yeah nice work we're going to be
back in a moment we've got a Vib ribbon
finally if you think this was scary you
just wait Vib ribbon uh finally came
Ahad in North America we're going to
play that in a second and speaking of
scary nonsense that NBA 2K trailer I
don't think their own trailer has all
those stupid faces in I don't think they
would put that in the trailer no well
that's fine there but it's all over the
internet
we couldn't be happier with how 2K4
turned out it was a long year for us and
we came a long way and we're just so
happy with how it turned out especially
visually we felt like as a gameplay team
that we had to step up this year winning
takes Talent obviously to repeat like
this takes character that's something
that this team is going to do this year
it's something that they've always done
2K14 will improve received really high
praises we came out graphically
animation wise and we set out to kind of
really top that even for 15 the biggest
competitor for us is ourselves we want
to put out a better game than what we
did last
year the start of the year I told the
guys that you know we really wanted to
have a game that was balanced and that
was that felt good on on both ends of
the floor this year we have a new
technology called situational Tech so
with this technology we've been able to
rewrite defense we've changed up how
we're rotating on defense how early we
rotate we've Incorporated things like
defensive IQ player IQ we like to think
that it's kind of a new living and
breathing organism now so the AI is able
to recognize things they're able to see
things on the court that a user can
see for 2K15 we captured over 5,000
animations contact animations in the
paint uh on the floor between the ball
handler and the defender just going to
the rim is a lot more visceral defense
Collision we really didn't leave any
tables unturned as far as the upgrades
are
concerned I think what fans are going to
love most about NBA 2K15 is just the
overall experience everything has been
touched from top to bottom from modes to
online and especially gameplay there's
just so much in there it's such a fully
featured game a lot more competitive and
really mirrors real life
basketball on a daily basis we have this
challenge that we have to face making
sure that we live up to that and that's
the difference that's why you get a
great product year after year is just
the determination to be the best and
just the love and passion for
basketball in the thing hello how you
doing you enjoying the show I'm having a
blast
who's he talking to uh audience audience
members he's talking to audience right
now yeah he does this it's like a thing
to connect does he know they don't talk
back yeah does he know that he doesn't
the voices Oh the Danny's
voices mckinness hey have arrived we
have Sean you look different since the
last time I saw you do you want to shake
my hand bring it bring it in what going
you've had a flu shot so I did show me
your sweet Band-Aid I got a Band-Aid of
a skateboarding dinosaur I don't know if
you guys right broking it there's like a
dinosaur and it's wearing a helmet over
here it hurts the things I do for
internet television but uh that's
definitely a skateboarding dinosaur does
that mean you're going to have the flu
tomorrow like just a little bit going to
call in sick for the next 3 weeks sorry
guys that flu shot was a real Barn s was
a bad idea you look different to the
last time I saw you thanks yeah oh right
cuz of the the scanning face yeah last
time I saw you was in NBA 2k is it that
I don't look like an abomination of
nature oh look there you go yeah it
doesn't look like you've been beaten
about the face with household
appliances horrific uh bruising I don't
understand it's like you your skin paint
was like buffed off and revealing the
robot
beneath yeah that was fun that was fun
we're not here to play NBA 2K15 H it
would have been on the show like maybe
but uh son it got bumped anything could
have happened I don't know anything that
will happen can happen good and Sony or
yeah Sony of America decided to that's
not what they're
called Sony nintend Entertainment
America's company Sony they decided to
to finally put out skia Tod to finally
put out uh Vib ribbon um I feel like the
only reason that this has been released
in North America is because of like
softcore internet trolling like
everyone's just saying you
guys com and everybody's like turns out
we don't know what the [__] Vib Rhythm
actually is you what the actual title of
the game is VI Rhythm vid Rhythm VI
ribbon Vib ribbon ribbon VI is the name
of the I don't know what it's called see
this is a game that was released in
Japan and then released in Europe a
couple of months later in like 99 Never
released in North America it's the folks
who made PaRappa the Rapper yeah Nana
Ona great M Messiah mats baby really
major miners Majestic
March a we
B leing on the Wii you read that one for
gam.com oh yeah it's not good so it's
out today on PS3 and Vita and PS4 oh oh
really but P so the thing with this game
is that you can use audio CDs to
generate levels only works on the PS3
version okay uh let's Jump Right In
you're going to do it yeah well I think
who have you played it before yeah only
like a little bit this morning and then
like 10 years ago yeah I I haven't
played about 10 years it is so so it's
it's pretty simple there's only four
buttons but then they combine the
buttons to I mean let's just get to it
I'll show you honestly I was reading the
description of it and it sounded a lot
like a bit trip Runner yes Mary was
saying that earlier as well which you
know I mean this is not going to go well
it's way harder wait you you haven't
done the tutorial have you uh no but I
mean I know what to do what song is
it uh it's from of the rapper oh [__]
this is a song from oh we're instantly
going into your CD yeah okay H what is
happening there are four buttons and you
like what are they one of them is fall
down and die the other one is fall down
and die another one is Jump there's a
duck there's a fall down and dive it's
so hard so the problem is is that like
that's triangle that's X okay wa but the
problem is that there are modifiers on
all these so sometimes the circle has
like a triangle on it sometimes you have
to do or two and
square it starts off really easy and
then it just oh no see this is really
embarrassing this is why maybe maybe you
should switch to to your backup song you
got turned into a worm bring it back and
then you die that CD keep playing we've
got the CD yeah don't use that use the
default music
what actual music so people can see what
it's like can I do the tutorial where's
the tutorial I don't know do you have to
is there a tutorial I think you got to
take out that CD
back do yeah yeah we we have to see it
turn plug out that CD plug out CD like
Danny says plug out it's been a while
since I used Optical media okay hey
could you uh plug out that CD thanks
just plug it right out that' be
great I don't see no there's no tutorial
Man play with Fi and disc I did that
already here we go is it noney all right
do an easy one do an easy one and then
after that do your special song Peter
you know which one I'm talking about
yeah I do okay plug out that disc is
that what you said plug out that CD plug
out the
disc so this is the reason to get it on
PS how much is it I don't know six bucks
it cost you like six bucks Mary what are
the four buttons you got the r buttons
which does the loop R like R1 or R2 if
you fancy okay what just
happened someone plugged a disc out yeah
did you plug the disc in or plug it out
I hate you
guys oh did you think you would be able
to make one small error in speech and
not like ride that one for the rest of
the
segment this is so much easier than when
you were doing that last one do you hit
it at the beginning of the loop you hit
it like right when the foot touches the
the element all right so that's the R
button what's this one that's an X what
is that a tumble
sure vid ribbon Vib Rhythm or VI rib
ribbon Vib ribbon a vibrating ribbon Viv
ribbon oh Vib ribbon but the the bunny
is called Vib vibri the Vib ribbon bun
get those waves there were two sequels
to this as well well but they were
considerably different though rib viven
right one of them created levels using
predefined like pictures like pixelated
pictures and there was another one I
forget how that one worked
X R1 it's like you got this R1 oh I can
just do back flips the whole time why
weren't you doing this woo X where are
the other ones L do
L okay nutted yourself on that column
Chris is there any way of getting down
hit down is there any way of making it
so you're not taking anymore no you
always have that if you mess up yes how
many times can you mess up I don't know
you're the expert on this video game oh
wow expert I think nope I this was in
the era before seizure warnings too is
it freaking you head a little bit that's
your flu shot okay this is like uh not
many games use vectors since the
vect but yeah all these Graphics are
done using uh vectors premature it's
fine is if anyone care
I talking over each other I like the
vector graphics you don't see a lot of
that why are you a frog now cuz I was
doing poorly you de evolved from rabbit
to frog a natural order of things if you
do really crap like Peter I become a
worm I remember when people in the chat
are like this came out in 2000 what the
hell I remember when this came out in
Europe thinking this looks like a piece
of
[__] that was 15 years ago Sean you want
to give this one a
shot no yes look at this get your
multiplier the around first what button
is it l or L2 down R something yeah
there you go oh feel
it do it Frogger yeah I know what's up x
x you got that Rhythm ribbon Rhythm
oh oh what's that one L down R you are
just the worst r r r l l r yes r r r r
oh it's a worm yeah you all right let's
let's do do uh you know what now you
want to do your song yeah I'll do it all
right I switch out plug in the
disc plug plug in the compa disc you
plug up you plug it up or you plug it
out okay plug i foret x plug it in plug
it in listen you got you got bumped back
up to Rabbit you better get your rabbit
game on just put it in oh my goodness PL
it in you're terrible I wish Japan were
in the OR song contest yeah all right
headit start get out of
here uh back go down o no I for one I'm
delighted that this game is out but I
will not be purchasing why are you
delighted that this game is out is it
like because it's a dumb game do you
have like historical interest like do
you like the fact that like kind of
obscure games from the
past like you know come back are are
re-released are sort of kept in the in
mix in circulation I like it because
it's because this was a game that people
in Europe were like you know America
didn't get this oh okay so it's kind of
like the fact that it's been finally
released here is kind it was like an
exclusive you felt like you were part of
a cool Club no nobody felt down no R
down R RL down so the modifiers are on
these ones oh [__] so instead of regular
cir you do it you do it they're like
this is terrible you got this
whoa
what the song is this this is Sean's
Choice by the way Peter asked me to pick
a song and I picked Snake Eater from the
video game Metal Gear Solid 3 Snake
Eater this is a up it's great so it's
going to be about 7 minutes long you
know Peter's going to be a worm before
we even God damn it Chris I'm tired of
this [__] you're a worm right
now by [__] do you mean the truth
the truth you're just a mean mean man go
for it Peter I believe in you shut up
I believe
R1 R down it doesn't even seem to be in
with the music no it's not at
all maybe not the best song it's not
this is the best song objectively go
maybe not for vid it's going the other
direction that was difficult Sean you
got to play your own song No I'm going
to fail it even all right we're going to
play one more you got it do you want to
you want to the last one I want to I too
how many more times do we have to play
loads as many as we want awesome all
right you you pick your track okay
I will say let's save four for the the
last or [__] play it now which one is
four keep the current
CD this one how many trucks are on this
four what was the where was met like
your solid uh there was two three have
we done three yet three was the one we
just did what's what was one that was
prop of the rapper really hard one yeah
four four yeah do it you can do it I
believe let's see those Euro gaming
skills because it's seeus
plug in my skills at any pretend you're
playing pretend you're playing sensible
soccer on your BBC micro back home in
Waterford God damn
it stupid rabbit I hated you then I hate
you now this is not the Waterford Way no
this is not oh one no that's or no this
one is complicated as hell yeah I feel
like I can do this one now after that
like the bronze level look it's like
they're not even stationary
young Danny would be so disappointed
think of young Danny just trying to make
it big in the big city one day young
Danny is wondering why they would
release this game 15 years
later Danny's like I can't this is neat
but I can't wait until they have
spiritual successors to this game that
are way better yeah like bit trip Runner
2 with oculus rift support oh jeez
Oculus bman what if this game was a
firstperson platformer with Rift support
wouldn't that be
great in my local GameStop this was like
there was always like 20 of these in the
pre-owned section really yeah [__] no
cuz I think they sold it for like
20 whatever Euro or pounds back
then come on
froggy how all this is going to do is
make people start asking for a HG reased
propo now that would have been a better
decision to be honest with you I bet I
bet this one took one person about a
week HD re-release like does Parappa and
HD really look better than just Parappa
they just want to play it again sure cuz
our silly median makes it so that you
can't like play stuff that's old without
considerable amounts of effort couldn't
you just play the PS1 Classics or the uh
PS1 whatever whatever you can use the
PlayStation one disc even on the PS3
yeah so uh are you are you talking for
the music or just generator you play PR
of the ra or PlayStation one on your PS3
with the disc but it has to be backwards
compatible one right no that's only PS2
you're kidding all the PS This everyone
says this to me anytime I bring this
[__] up I did not know that what is do
are you guys qualified for your jobs
what the
hell you're our resident [__] playing
old video games dude yeah that's that's
true that is true man no I do not yeah
so yeah it's totally true I'm going to
start ebaying PS1 games incredibly
difficult I don't I don't even know
Heckle me from over there oh my God say
the to Heckle you got to be on set I'm
not even TR the obstacles are definitely
not in sync with the Rhythm I'll tell
you that
much he get this game is very difficult
24 yeah I'll try it again I'm beat 24
come on just let it happen what are you
so busy doing we have the pie resistance
up after this all right I'm not going to
play that one cuz which one is that oh
is that's your special song it's the
song that there is a running bet in
Gamespot for the past I feel like 9
months maybe I think it's Mary's idea
whereas if you can get this edited into
any like video on the size there's a
kitty jar how much is it in the jar at
the moment do not understand that I am
Mar just ran out room right now are is
is Peter technically winning this bat
yes uh that's going to have to that's
going to have to be adjudicated I feel
like by a jury of his peers I got Space
Monkey into a video on the site okay
technically I gave you the file oh my
God technically you gave me the file but
this is really difficult I could have
acquired it by by other means Mary give
me that money you got the
jar what do you mean I didn't earn
it I'm the responsible for this being on
air am I not it's played okay so okay
all right does this count does he win
the face monkey it's going towards beer
if I win it anyway so that's true in
that case yes okay before we play before
we play let's see let's count it up
space Money Pot jar wait does that we
have to bite we to spend it on pot
monkey pot we could do that that's
fine oh it's already been SP a pot five
10 there's way more here than I thought
they'd be there's some fake money in
there that's fake Payday 2 money bonus
bucks thanks that you TI it's probably
Tai 15 20 there's 5 Euro in here as well
there's a twoo count it and then or two
Australians no Singapore bucks oh Jesus
listen for the International Truck we
wanted to make it appealing to folks
from All Nation
oh okay you guys video producers atot so
this just 20 bucks there if you beat
this level oh I have to beat the level
[__] all right Peter you can do this
crank it
up oh my goodness I hear Rob every time
I hear this
song this is
doable you can see why there was a best
to try and get this song into a video it
also had to be like at least 30 seconds
40 how has this not been done yet you
just sneak it into any old video yeah
you just put it into for Horizon 2 video
review alien isolation video review yeah
the destiny raid guide videos just put
this into an NBA 2K15 gameplay clip
you're killing it buddy you got
this uh I think the closest we came was
trying to put it into the Donkey Kong
Country Tropical Freeze one but it
didn't quite land 40 seconds of this
song it turns out is actually quite a
lot it's actually a a lot
[__] is this part of our music library
is that okay come on
froggy get them Space Monkey
books no this is what we were listening
to while we were playing Vib ribbon in
Europe that whole
time stack the shelves stack the
shelves you're not digging it Sean I'm
digging it I'm just trying to focus
you're a frog already [__] you can do
this Peter come on get it together man
oh it's Rob Rob's here this is not this
count 30 seconds flat no vo 30 seconds
flat with no vo no that was never the
best it was full
volume okay I'll do it again and you
guys shut up we've got Rob we've got Rob
Handler contesting let's definitely not
talk after 29 seconds okay oh yeah let's
Okay after thus nullifying the BET Peter
yeah five bucks for me to shut up this
whole time oh wait so does it count cuz
you're getting game audio too you get
all the weird squeaks from the bunny
demon thing that should be fine we
usually
unadorned mic if he splits it with
Don wants to split all right I could
also run over there and turn off the
PS3 sabotage the I mean this beer is for
all of us Sean I'm going to use this
internet timer to get 30 seconds you
still that says 5 minutes Twi I I can
subtract when it hits 4 minutes and 30
seconds all right get in there all right
I'm getting in it and
go
ha
You Laugh You Laughed you laugh and said
was 45 seconds in oh my God that was
over 30 seconds yeah here for everyone
Studio anded he sold me the
Frog oh good work it smells dirty wait
no dump it over him dump it over him
this is that Gold Club M
yeah there was also a quarter in
there that's for you nice work I'm rich
B now buy us beer thank
you Peter Brown man of the people Rob's
going to Rob's going to run run in here
with like another
stipulation is it is that I think this
is the best possible outcome for that
bet how long was at n
months like y everyone's good for
something
yes thank you thank you my people done
Peter nicely done all right that is uh
that's a show for this week uh last
things last we had this TGs swag bag we
showed a couple of weeks ago H last week
uh we didn't the winner I have one of
those at home I'm married
man godamn it and the winner is can we
get a drum
roll muddy logarithm yeah
math oh yeah you know that dude what I
just know what the word logarithm means
oh math jokes I thought you said Matt
julks congratulations mat jks if your
name is Matt
jokes let us know oh julks always
winning stuff lucky lucky son of a gun
should we go get some beer yeah all
right thanks very much everyone for you
have to bring the jar
though yeah good man I'll take 12 of
your finest and you got to First pay him
in Singapore Euro and PayDay I'm sorry
does that not okay yeah no I'm sure I've
got something in here uh does this
no great I'm in let's go get some drinks
all right thanks very much everyone for
watching it's been a Lobby for this week
we'll see you next week Tuesday to be
pacific we did
it
yeah